S
THINK OF THE INITIAL IMPACT BUT
AFTER THAT.
LOOK WE KNOW DURING ANY CRISIS,
WHETHER IT'S A NATURAL DISASTER
OR OTHERWISE, WE SEE MORE THAN
EVER WE LEADERSHIP MATTERS.
COMPETENT, ARTICULATE,
REASSURING LEADERSHIP.
THE DEVASTATING HURRICANE WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT POUNDING
FLORIDA, IT'S GOING TO LEAVE
ENORMOUS DAMAGE IN ITS WAKE, WE
CAN SEE IT.
EVACUATION ORDERS, ASSISTANCE,
THEY'RE UNDERWAY, AND NOW
MINIMIZING THE LOSS OF LIFE AND
ORGANIZING THE RECOVERY EFFORTS
ARE WHAT MATTERS MOST.
>> THE STORM IS DOING A NUMBER
ON THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
IT IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
THROUGH THIS STATE TODAY AND
THROUGH MUCH OF TOMORROW.
AND THERE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE A NUMBER OF ADVERSE EFFECTS.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT AS SOON AS
IT MOVES BEYOND SOUTHWEST
FLORIDA, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
MASSIVE SURGE OF PERSONNEL AND
SUPPLIES TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED GET PEOPLE
BACK ON THEIR FEET AND HELP TO
REBUILD THOSE COMMUNITIES.
>> Laura: AND LEADERS DON'T JUST
READ WHAT OTHER PEOPLE PUT IN
FRONT OF THEM.
THEY'RE NOT PERFORMANCE ARTISTS,
NOT REALLY, RIGHT?
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN ALL ASPECTS OF
MANAGING DIFFICULT CHALLENGES
AND DIRECTING, AS DeSANTIS WAS
JUST DOING, THE PROPER RESOURCES
TO WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED MOST.
>> WE'RE GOING IN BY GROUND,
AIR, AND BY SEA, MEAN THES ALL
HANDS ARE ON DECK AND THERE'S
GOING TO BE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO BE IN HARM'S WAY AND
WHAT I'VE SAID IS, YOU KNOW,
FOLKS WERE TOLD IN THESE AREAS
OF THE HAZARDS, YOU KNOW, THEY
WERE GIVEN TIME TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE ARRANGEMENTS AND TO LEAVE,
SOME CHOSE NOT TO DO THAT.
THEY WOULD HAVE PROBABLY BEEN
BETTER OFF DOING THAT.
NEVERTHELESS, IF PEOPLE ARE IN
HARM'S WAY, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND DO WHATEVER WE
CAN TO HELP THOSE FOLKS.
AND SO THAT IS GOING TO -- THOSE
OPERATIONS ARE GOING TO COMMENCE
AS SOON AS IT'S SAFE TO DO SO
AND THEN IT BEGINS WITH THE
CLEARING THE ROADS, MAKING SURE
THAT THE ELECTRICAL FOLKS CAN
GET IN THERE.
I WAS ABLE TO THANK A NUMBER OF
THESE LINEMEN.
WE WENT OVER TO LAKE CITY WHERE
A NUMBER OF THEM ARE STAGED.
THESE ARE GREAT FOLKS.
THEY'RE COMING FROM ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN, I MEANT PEOPLE FROM
ALABAMA, FROM TEXAS, FROM
LOUISIANA.
THEY'RE ALL COMING TO FLORIDA.
>> Laura: AND BECAUSE NO PERSON,
NOT ONE PERSON CAN DO
EVERYTHING, YOU NEED GOOD PEOPLE
IN POSITION AT A SENIOR LEVEL TO
HELP MANAGE IN A TIME OF
EMERGENCY.
>> YOU THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
EXTREMELY COMMITTED TO BEING
INVOLVED IN THIS RESPONSE AND HE
WAS HERE WITH ME UNTIL LATE LAST
NIGHT AND HE WAS HERE WITH ME
EARLY THIS MORNING AND HE HAS
NOT BEEN ANYWHERE BUT VERY NEAR
ME THE ENTIRE TIME SO GOVERNOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THAT AREA.
I MEAN, IT MEANS A LOT TO ME, IT
MEANS A LOT TO THE LEADERSHIP.
>> Laura: WELL, I'M NOT IN
FLORIDA, BUT I WAS REASSURED BY
SEEING THE TEAM THAT DeSANTIS
HAD IN PLACE.
IT'S WHY LEADERSHIP MATTERS.
BECAUSE IT FILTERS DOWN.
BECAUSE IT INSPIRES PEOPLE IN A
TIME OF NEED WHEN, FRANKLY,
INSPIRATION'S HARD TO COME BY.
THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA ARE UNDER
SIEGE BY HURRICANE WINDS, NOW
FLOODING, AND THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED ENORMOUS ASSISTANCE GOING
FORWARD AND RIGHT NOW ALL WE CAN
DO IS HOPE AND PRAY AND DONATE
TO THE RED CROSS AND OTHER GREAT
CHARITABLE EFFORTS AND THEN WE
REMAIN GRATEFUL TO PUB